when I was quite young around four years
old we moved into a subdivision called
the hills of Delafield and it's still
out there it's now very populated back
then there really weren't many people
living in it I think we were either the
second or the third family to move into
it and it took a long time for it to
develop and I think it had been there
for quite some time because as I recall
the roads were already a little bit worn
and old when we first came in
and if you don't know where Delafield is
so it's a it's a Township and also a
town in Wisconsin if you look at where
Interstate 94 and Highway 83 come
together well that's Delafield and then
we lived much closer to the Village of
Wales which begins around where 80 E3
and Highway 18 come together so if you
go up 83 about a mile from that
intersection and then you look on the uh
you know as you're driving north the
right hand side which would be the the
East well there's the entrance to the
hills of Delafield Glacier Pass which is
a long windy road that goes all the way
around and then comes back to Highway 83
and there's a few cul-de-sacs these
places where the road leaves into
another place like uh you know Gray Fox
Run was the closer one and then there's
like a little turn around there and so
anyway
we moved out there and I've talked about
this in some of the other stories and
one of the cool things that happened
quite a lot when we were young and
before many houses came in there was
aeronauts balloon people would have
their hot air balloons these gigantic
things right and they would
um land them on Glacier Pass and we saw
this happening a number of times it
became less and less frequent as the
subdivision began to fill up with houses
but it was still going on I would say
probably from you know 1975 to maybe
1978 or 1979 which is a long time when
you're a kid right so those years seem
to to cover a long long period
and what would typically happen is you
know we would play outside much of the
time uh even in winter but particularly
from Spring through summer to Autumn and
you know you could see this hot air
balloon usually quite colorful with its
Gondola that people were in
flying you know just sort of gliding
through the air and coming closer and
slowly coming down and they must have
been quite good at guiding these because
I mean the road is not super super wide
I suppose maybe some of the time they
would wind up Landing in the Prairies or
Meadows that were you know what ended up
becoming a lot of the Yards because the
you know the road which I mentioned you
know is kind of winding it wasn't a
straight road
there would be in some cases you know
scrub or Woods near to the road but in
other cases there'd be Fields
um you know and nothing out there was
very evenly graded the school district
was called Kettle Moraine and it's
called that because of the geographical
features uh that were left behind by the
the glaciers kettles you know these sort
of depressions and uh moraines you know
another kind and then there were all
sorts of hills and things like that so
we would typically be outside or
somebody in the family would be outside
and they would spot a balloon coming in
and the very first couple times we were
like just in awe and we'd see this
coming down onto the road and you know
it would be gliding with the wind but
also descending fairly quickly and if
they timed it just right or if the wind
was blowing just right they would manage
to land the balloon which then you know
the the bucket the gondola would hit and
and it would be kind of you know
jostling around then you see the balloon
itself collapsing coming down around
hopefully not on top of the people
directly but off on the side and there'd
usually be you know anywhere from two to
four people in these balloons and
dressed up uh kind of warmly because it
does get chilly up there and you know we
would watch as this happened it was it
was like people coming from
um you know somewhere else not outer
space but they certainly weren't like us
and they were usually fairly young
people like you know college student age
I suppose and this was like a a big
thing in the area and it probably
happened
every two or three months sometimes
there'd be you know more of them at any
particular time like maybe they'd be
only a couple weeks apart and then we'd
go out and uh you know we'd meet them
and they'd be you know literally in the
middle of nowhere uh back at that time
the whole area was very undeveloped you
know there was the village of Wales and
there was like a grocery store there and
a couple churches and you know the local
elementary school and then Delafield was
you know way down the road and there
were restaurants in Delafield but the
closest restaurant when we first moved
in was a drive-in called dog and suds
way down off of Highway 83. that was it
that was for quite a while that was all
the that was around there so they're
Landing like I said in the middle of
nowhere and there was no cell phones at
the time so what they would have to do
is because they were way waiting for
somebody to come and get them somebody
to come and pick them up they weren't
going to like fly their balloon back up
or anything like that they were Landing
it after whatever Journey they were on
was finished and I suppose they must
have typically have been coming from the
west and the north because that's the
way the winds typically blow so I don't
know maybe they started out in Madison
or one of the other you know towns along
the uh the interstate or you know
further north or something like that and
you know so my dad would go out there
and my mom and it was like a big thing
and my sister we'd all go out there and
we're you know our eyes are big the kids
at least like saucers and then my dad
would you know shake hands with
everybody and he my mom would chat with
them and they'd say hey you want to do
you need to make a phone call you can
come back to our house and uh use our
our phone and so that you know they'd
leave their balloon there it's not like
anyone was gonna be driving on the road
uh and you know so sometimes they'd like
pull it off on the side and sometimes
they just leave it right in the middle
of the road
and then you know like one of them would
come back with my mom or my dad to make
the phone call you know it's usually a
walk of about a quarter to a half a mile
to our our house and then they'd we just
all wait around until like somebody
would come out with a truck or sometimes
I think I remember a big van and they'd
you know put everything inside there and
then they they'd take off they'd say
thanks and and that was that was that
but one of the things that I do remember
about this and it leads to some regrets
on my part my dad was into home movies
and he had what was called a super eight
camera so eight millimeter and you know
it was kind of big and bulky he would
sometimes let me or my sister play
around with it and shoot some stuff but
mostly it was him shooting it and I know
that we had footage
of a whole bunch of these you know
walking out there he'd be like filming
and you could see the balloon actually
coming down and the people like waving
and
um you know
you you couldn't hear any sound because
the Super 8 didn't have sound but you'd
see people like doing this you know like
they're talking and
um it was really quite something and we
would we would watch these right he
would take movies of things and then
we'd set up this projection screen and
there was an actual projector and you
put the The Reel of the movie in there
and it would you know make that a sound
as it's uh going through and it'd be
projected and we'd be like yeah that's
the time that this thing happened and do
you remember that it was a way of
reminiscing together I remember we would
always watch these in the basement
because it was you know the one place
that we could be assured would be dark
enough if we turn the lights off that
you could get a really good image it was
pretty rare that we would set up the uh
the film stuff upstairs I think we'd
only be able to do it at night really
and so we would watch these movies and
unfortunately
um we didn't keep them my mom did she
actually had like
boxes of the movies that my dad had
recorded and when she died uh you know
and my sister and I went through all of
her stuff my sister was like well do you
want these old movies and I was like
well I don't have any place to put them
so my sister took them and like many of
the things that she took Unfortunately
they got lost in various moves that she
did she also had a pretty bad boyfriend
who who got rid of a lot of her stuff
that she had inherited and they just
disappeared all of this this footage of
all sorts of other things besides the
balloons but the balloons are the thing
that I actually remember the best
because you know we we did those things
he recorded it we watched it together
and then these
um films just kind of went where they
they were going to be and so
that's the story there's not much more
to tell about that but it was something
kind of interesting to remember and I
thought I would tell you about it here
I'm not quite sure what to make of it
but I was thinking about it the other
day and thought it could be something
enticing
interesting whatever you want to think
about it just think of this image of the
balloons the colorful balloons coming
down out of the air in the 1970s and all
of us running out to see what these
people were doing